is
[Music]
boy that sure can't talk yeah it's like
we get at 12 years fam and pestilence I
mean get a new thing lady yeah all right
we'll uh just check back tomorrow and
see if God protects her or whatever
Sunrise o'clock all right see ya
all right
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
Ahoy
all right
I can't hear anything in my headphones I
Now understand what Steven's complaining
but he keeps them really low he does
yeah he doesn't want to blow his ears
out oh I have uh man ears ah
hey it's gonna be exciting today we're
gonna be talking a lot we're talking
about Elon Musk is he Chinese oh my
goodness
Balenciaga update involves a penis nosed
owl seriously I know they're on back
order I've been waiting media reports
fake news on Iran there's also a
heartwarming story of a Canadian woman
offered assistance by the government and
mug Club we're going to be playing they
don't make them like they used to little
Sean Connery 007 Edition
and also question of the day uh on a
scale of one to ten how insane do you
think he is yay whatever is Kanye West
how insane do you think Kanye West is
after seeing his appearance on Alex
Jones raping psycho we'll know because
Alex Jones will actually be here
tomorrow
you can make Alex Jones feel
uncomfortable on your
oh you're like oh okay you might be
saying something spicy uh he was
laughing in discomfort and it was it was
fun to watch he filed the filed for
bankruptcy the very next day I don't
think that timing had anything to do
with it
I'm sure it was a blow to the ego I uh
but you can see me December 16th and
17th at the Funny Bone in Syracuse New
York and uh the other thing sounded this
weekend I'll be at the Comedy Castle in
Detroit yeah so come out in Detroit they
do have a castle in it they have a few
castles they do but before we get into
this let's go ahead Gerald a how are you
doing today well sir how are you I'm
fine I'm alive how was the uh the the
finishing leg of the Fall tour the
rebels with a cause tour it was amazing
the people in Jersey and Baltimore were
absolutely incredible awesome I can't
thank you guys enough for coming out and
supporting and everybody here who has
supported us through this whole tour
thank you so much we it means the world
to us it really does and uh except uh
you know one play we don't want to talk
about it
um
I know every place was good every place
was fun uh token now and how are you
Ahoy Dave Ahoy to you akuza
good morning good morning
that's better Tim the Tool Man good
morning sir good morning he was with us
all weekend no yeah somebody actually
gave me this hat was oh really yeah or
uh in jerseys uh he was operating the
spot oh that's awesome screw it up to
the camera let's read that let's pull it
up okay don't blame me I voted for Trump
yeah I like it I like it and uh someone
gave us some some stuff too
we'll get herpes yeah I have that as
well we'll save uh that discussion yeah
and we'll save that discussion for
another day warts anyway and we also
have one of my favorite people crawdaddy
how you doing today doing great David
thank you yes you were also on the tour
with us this weekend I wasn't everyone
slept in the plane but you and I sat up
and talked yeah so you crapped out on me
eventually and snored I I passed out for
like a good 20 minutes that's right but
I woke up just to hear the stories of
the people that had been on the plane
recently and I liked that you were very
confused when you woke up yes it was
like George Clooney and O Brother Where
out dark you know my hair yeah yeah like
where did I go I thought I was just
eating cheese a minute ago where's my
Dapper Dan yes
[Laughter]
well and you were in the end people love
taking photos with you
you know the odd photo come on you guys
take thousands yeah but then they're
like is that crawdaddy get into this
photo or they run to you to take the
picture they love you I like how Steven
called you out in Baltimore because he
saw your silhouette I was standing right
behind Tim yeah
stashed enough light yeah he said get
get get out of it he literally just saw
your outline
get out of my eyeline and John bailed on
me just took off and I'm left holding
the bag yeah yes I know these fans are
great though they are such great people
and I love to see how they interact with
you guys and they're just so fiercely
loyal it's great they really are nice
people and we had Thomas Finnegan uh
smoking a cigarette in every historic
theater so that was important
this place was built in 1898 and he
lights up yep it's an addiction Darren I
mean that speed yeah you can't get
through an eight-minute set
so let's talk about this this year is
2022 that's a good and true which means
people are getting more insane by the
day uh here we have a female tick tocker
who's growing out of her body hair
growing growing out her body hair I saw
enough that wasn't there
gonna be fun today I know I have Lasik
but I also get Starbursts we were
talking about this so everything to me
has a glare oh no yeah Christmas lights
must kill you oh they're fun though if
my hppd kicks in it's like a little Acid
Trip well you're too young for reading
glasses yet you don't need them to read
not yet no no I'm definitely gonna need
them though it's a good trade-off
distance Vision with Lasik for the deal
but now they can do the whole bionic eye
thing with the new lens so I don't know
if I'm there yet but I did do the laser
thing and everybody's like a laser in
your eyes and I'm like it's awesome it's
a piece of cake yeah I think mine took
six minutes and then after they you
sleep for eight hours and it's done it's
the greatest recoup time ever you can
get Lasik by me at Dave's lasik.com he's
a professional yes professional what uh
don't worry about it I will fix your
eyes thanks for that Casey Casey
uh yeah but here you go here's the
female tick tocker who's growing out her
body hair wants you to know about it wow
you're so observant and yeah I do have
belly hair I also have armpit hair ew
back hair dip it
leg hair
and arm hair I don't really know she's
Italian yes
actually we're like grows hair and then
I don't do anything about it because
there's no rules saying that you have to
gross that's a Treasure Trail because it
doesn't go up to her mouth
foreign
[Laughter]
there's no law that says I have to have
no body hair yeah but you know
shave it yeah I mean having a little bit
of arm hair okay fine that's I don't
think that's a big deal no the chest
belly like the trail hair I'm like ah
it's a little weird well you're doing it
you're wearing a shirt that shows off
that particular area of the body and
then you're complaining that people
notice that you're like hey
are you French Italian something where
they have hair all over the place and
she's just like no I'm a dick
little Austin Powers tuft yes yes yes
she has a giant uh just Burt Reynolds
yeah
just just a bare skin rug of a of a
cleavage
I don't understand the virtue in it I
guess just don't be pissed off that
people are like that's a little weird
which is why young lady we're sending
you a free manscape yes there you go you
can enjoy that and stop grossing out
your boyfriend this holiday season but
wait kids in a family here you go yes
also also good news men are disgusting
and don't really care if they're drunk
enough you're drunk enough
you're gonna get banged all right
I'm just being honest like if I was
hammered in high school like that girl
looks like Sprite in college and
somebody was like I have some chest hair
and pit hair I'd be like whatever
I do shave my forearms though that's the
bridge too yes this one's here this is
the looking like a gorilla yeah
give me an arm
good old she's quarter Sasquatch is what
happened
[Laughter]
well good luck to her uh I think you're
gonna make a man very miserable yes
on Friday night Elon Musk dropped a slew
of files that showed Democrats directly
uh colluding with Twitter to censor
information they didn't like this was
huge it was massive I was watching the
whole thing it was five o'clock Friday
yeah yeah the announced via Twitter uh
the the thread that Matthew is it
Tybee yeah I had to ask for
pronunciation clarification as well yeah
but he put it all out there more
expected to be released today we'll be
covering that tomorrow when Steven's
back at the desk and of course on that
interview will be none other than Alex
Jones yes Deep dive because like you
said there's more coming out today our
guys are going through every single
piece of information they can possibly
go through to get all the details I know
everybody wants to talk about this story
and we should because it shows Dems
being caught red-handed it also leads to
some Shenanigans with Trump that we'll
talk about tomorrow in his response to
all of this so stay tuned for that it's
really fascinating just what came out
though and how corrupt this is oh yeah
oh it's beautiful to see well and it's
the response from everybody one going
after this guy and two kind of saying
that this is really nothing it's just
all penis pics of Hunter Biden I'm like
okay yeah you didn't read any of this
because James Woods didn't send a penis
pic and that's not why he was asked to
be removed so yeah you're gonna this
could end up in some really interesting
legal he's gonna sue the DNC yes he
hopes enough people will draft him
behind him I'm sure he's looking at a
class action oh yeah yeah absolutely
because he can't afford to do that he'd
wear him out oh for sure yeah yeah I bet
Merrick Garland's going to take Swift
action yes uh
we did good on that one yeah it doesn't
have to keep things Frozen this winter
[Laughter]
God he's an awful yeah anyway
today though
we're going to talk a little bit more
about Elon Musk if you guys want uh
Sunday on his Instagram Kanye West
hypothesized that Elon Musk is actually
a Chinese hybrid experiment allegedly
laughs
he put out some lovely little uh
messages such as am I the only one who
thinks Elon could be half Chinese have
you ever seen his fix as a child
well it's got like just a triple down
yeah he does all caps too yeah yeah oh
yeah yelling Grandpa yes
also he wrote take a Chinese genius and
make them with and make them with the
South African supermodel and you have
Elon
it's not a bad anyway no so far so good
on that yeah I mean I'd be like sure
I'll take that yeah you're saying that
yeah I'm a hot man we have n Elon and he
said we have an Elon yes because the
next part is where you know you thought
this was crazy to begin with well here's
when he says that uh I say an Elon
because they probably made 10 to 30
elons and he's the first genetic hybrid
that stuck well let's not forget about
Obama so
just it's science
I so I was like oh okay so he thinks a
Chinese spy they're a brilliant Chinese
person not a spy mated with a South okay
yeah fine and that's that's nice because
he's smart and he looks good that's what
he's saying and then he's like no you're
you're like part of a hybrid project
that's from a dystopian movie that we've
watched where most people didn't survive
but you finally did right well and if
you want go ahead and comment do you
think there's a lot of truth to this
I mean you're an idiot but go ahead and
comment
but make sure you you know one [ __ ] once
you start saying the qualities of Hitler
people don't listen to you anymore no
they shouldn't it's really just the
truth if you think this is all true just
let us know so that we can Mark you yeah
just I want to know where you are all
right so I can stay away from there
wherever there is Lord was that
something anyway speaking of Obama Elon
responded to this claim on his Twitter
saying I take that as a compliment ah
look at that there we go I can see that
it's nice Kanye then screen crack
screencap the tweet and posted it on his
Instagram with the reply it was meant as
a compliment my friend now Obama on the
other hand
again it would seem like trolling had it
not been for the Hitler Outburst well
you know
you know
all right so bad I'm gonna go ahead and
say this I know it takes some guts guys
take some guts go for it not a fan of
Hitler nor should you be I thought he
was bad how about Nazis no and I hate
Nazis yeah me too yeah I don't see the
point that was pretty simple right
you're kind of uh you're kind of
supporting a a party that's been dead
for some time
I think it's ridiculous if you consider
yourself one you're you're a silly Billy
I'll say it all right strong up my
silence mean anything other than you
guys are doing fine no okay I'm just
glad that you you're here look you don't
have to speak I agree
what a stupid thing to side with though
somebody's like yeah good qualities all
right hit the like button of course if
you don't like Hitler
uh I think that's important
uh let us know who you really are Don't
Be Afraid guys let's do this it's about
time take the heart stand he gets his
comeuppance
now uh after his now after Connie's
appearance on Alex Jones it's pretty
clear uh yay is insane but he might not
be completely wrong about Elon being
part Chinese yeah Elon actually sent us
some exclusive footage of him addressing
the claims hi everyone
money money
keep to you
that was actually three million dollars
and he didn't even pick it up no you
don't spin you don't pick up Pocket
Change now you drop a nickel you're like
that I'll just leave it
that's for the birds yeah some poor
unfortunate soul come along and pick
that up and have a better day yes
and if you're wondering about Yee's
Obama comments I don't know if it's here
yet it's if it's y-e it's yay I'm not
calling it yay because that's not how
it's spelled it needs it needs an accent
that they have in some languages yeah
yeah so yeah maybe an umlaut
oh boy so if you're what
is that racist that's an OverWatch it's
the two prongs is that what that is it's
a 2-0 things above the oh the umla in
French it's an axol a goo which is a
means it goes a instead of e in English
it's and I don't give a damn yeah
there's a great document called American
movie where the guy calls the movie
coven but he puts an umlaut over the O
and one of the actors is like well so
it's it's coven and he's like no it's
Kevin like witch he goes yeah but you
put an umlaut over the O so it's covered
you've been waiting to use that
reference no I've used it that's the
only reason I know what a new lot is
what do you think I learned at school
all right
so and uh and if you're wondering about
uh yay's Obama comments we've actually
obtained an unedited photo that the
former president doesn't want you to see
I lost it here we go no
[Laughter]
we had some Gremlins in the system this
morning
oh good I'm glad that was my face before
that went up
um
according to Morgan Stanley uh uh to a
Morgan Stanley analyst one half of
Tesla's profitability comes from the
Chinese market oh a wet Market oh no
different Market oh yeah do they have
drives they do but so the thing is he's
he's maybe not ethnically Chinese but he
is beholden it seems to China in a lot
of ways so we've touted him as being
this free speech Advocate and that's
right he's done some great things for
that but there are some shortcomings and
this is something that we always do we
did it with Donald Trump we do it with
everybody even if we love you if you're
not kind of doing some things that you
should be doing like speaking out on
protests or something like that then
we're going to call you out just a
little bit on that and so that's why
we're covering these things he depends
on a lot of his profit to come from
China so yeah is it a surprise that he's
been a little silent on things that are
happening
so yeah well in January Tesla even
opened a showroom in uh somebody else
say that xinjiang yep I think that's
close that's that's fair right xinjiang
yeah zigzag
I don't think it's that I don't know
what what you're gonna put an X and not
the word men after it you've lost me
Lanes losing his mind over there right
now oh I know he is yeah
well Elaine has a very good education
[Laughter]
I have an eighth grade education so what
do you do Lane
because you're smarter than me doesn't
mean you're smarter than me Musk
[Laughter]
is also praised China for their progress
in uh oh there's a word over that
sustainable energy
it's a select all
that joke's only for us I know
do we have the overlay there and the
sustainable energy ah if you seem to
realize that China is leading the world
in renewable energy generation and
electric vehicles whatever you may think
of China this is simply a fact
it's cool right yeah you like China it's
also a fact that when you fly in there's
a gray brown Cloud over the mainland as
you're coming off the ocean yeah oh it's
like LAX used to be I don't know if it's
still that way but uh but you mean like
Jersey was this weekend no offense guys
no offense but that's that's you know
get some big fans or something blow it
into New York if you have to oh my God
it's just it's all these chemical plants
it's just Pete you're you're all gonna
you're gonna die there's so much
pollutants well we're all gonna yeah
eventually I'm saying I mean if a meteor
was coming it's not even the worst news
we would have today that's true no one's
getting out of here alive today no yeah
that's what I've always said yeah that's
what the uh
so the doctor told me last week
I said especially you
then we kissed all right so the uh China
did I reread this hope not China is the
world's top polluter yeah no [ __ ] sorry
and it's responsible for the same amount
of carbon emissions as the as the next
four countries combined USA Indiana
Russia and Japan
uh just Indiana is a state in India
which Dave knows In fairness well
Indiana Indiana though equally as dirty
as India pretty close yeah so I don't
know why I just said Indiana slightly
less population
in Indiana though so no no bigger
crickets yeah yeah more into basketball
and football no I like good I like Parts
Indiana yeah part of it's nice just
because there's been people from there
watching and I want to perform there but
know your State's great
go get a great show there we did though
didn't we yeah those people were awesome
I do like Indiana's is that what they
call them Indians I don't think that's
whatever it is oh boy they would be
Indians
in Indiana indianans
it's got to be because the it's Indian
no oh really because they didn't just
add an a Geralds we're gonna get we're
gonna get our team on that we're gonna
find out what people from India Hoosiers
Hoosiers I knew that but yeah but back
to the stat that is pretty amazing those
countries on that list well because all
together yeah because China doesn't sign
on to these climate agreements and
everybody's like well we're committed to
doing this it's like number one accounts
for one through five yeah nobody else
matters if they sign on to this list
Switzerland's like yes we signed on and
we're like oh thank you yeah but we
appreciate it it's gonna make a big
difference well yeah USA India which is
extremely polluted Russia and Japan
which is very industrial yeah I couldn't
believe Japan was number five but yes
maybe scale that's incredible though
I mean that's a lot of I mean Greta
thunberg should go over there she should
go to China yeah go give uh Russia a bit
of lip yeah stop giving us a hard time
yeah we're trying what's this I know
it's Hoosiers but demean isn't indianans
we're Texans that's it oh they go with
Hoosiers what do you call someone from
Indiana Hoosier oh that would make sense
to their name but fine I'm gonna go
Indiana's and change it Oklahomans
they're also Sooners I'm saying it can
be both is that true yeah what's uh Indy
is there an Indiana State University
it's a community college it's an area
Andy's from Indiana that's right and she
said we never say Indiana in indianans
it's because it does I know I'm from
Michigan it's right there we've never
called it that michiganders Michigan
that's great Mission gangsters that's a
nice hand Mission not Misha gangsters
but Indiana means land of Indians yeah
so we say see how uncreative the name
was
way too much time on that yeah well I
don't think we did I think everybody
learned a little something today about
Indiana and Industrial China pollutes
and they buy a lot of electric cars yeah
yeah yes in a nutshell China is a a
terrible Place uh not that I've been I'm
sure that there's parts that are lovely
there's a wall I hear that's great hmm
74 000 babies die in the Wombie Year
from China from population pollution
I'm kind of [ __ ] I didn't sleep well
you know I'm not the only one who was on
tour so
yes uh seven let me reread that sentence
because it was so joyous 64 000 babies
die in the womb a year in China due to
pollution that's insane that is a lot
right so we We complain about the
pollution obviously how do you prove
that no I mean that is tough It's called
science we're not in the 1920s where we
take a guess at how people get sick why
baby die
maybe have a black longer yes
I keep throwing my plastic bottles away
in it
[Music]
littering killed your baby what yeah how
do you poop I do want to see Elon speak
out a little bit about the protest so I
don't think he's mentioned it at all yet
and this is a bit of a failing right
because there's some protests over
what's going on there especially as it
relates to production and coveted
policies and people being put in
internment camps and people being
potentially killed or not rescued in
fire sorry people being welded into
their Apartments like it's probably one
of those things that we should comment
on even if you have business interests
there so but what's the good news
helpful the good news I don't know I'm
just trying to make it well the good
news is he's doing something fantastic
with the Twitter files he's opening
these things up he's allowing people
back onto the platform and by the way
this is not a complete amnesty you get
to say whatever you want from here on
out thing it's come back to the platform
play by the rules of the platform that
will be open this time and fair and if
you can then you can stay on right I
like what he's saying and I think that's
a hundred percent reasonable but he is
missing an opportunity I think to call
something out now he doesn't have to
speak on every single issue I get it but
this is one of the biggest issues in the
world that every single major
corporation that we've talked about
including the NBA is silent on and
actually silencing people finding
coaches for talking about it removing
fans that were talking about Hong Kong
and held up signs like somebody just
needs to stand up and say this is bad
right or give them all starlinks so that
they can communicate with us without
having to go through the Chinese
Communist party I agree I have a Detroit
Pistons watch I still like basketball
but you guys are really starting to
upset me
so you put your fist down wow Dave easy
listen they're calling a meeting right
now Dave I know they're like this guy
right here
it's because they don't want me to play
that's right because I'm short I can't
do it but have you ever seen me dunk
yeah you have you're not supposed no one
has ever seen you ever nobody I tried to
do it on my son's Fisher Price for him
and I broke my knee uh you gotta go with
Little Tikes yeah I went I went little
jokes
they got myself a pair of Jordans I
jumped a quarter inch in the air it was
impressive and a trampoline and dunked
if I could dunk on a trampoline I
wouldn't be here right now I would be at
my house dunking on a trampoline Little
Tikes backboard yeah yeah so I would
School my son when he was like three I'd
be like bam out of my house and Trash
Talk of me yes go to your room no sadly
he's a better athlete Than Me by a lot
now well he's already going into like
travel like baseball and stuff where
that wasn't even close they'd like me to
travel out of right field and ride the
bench if they could have oh no I sucked
I did too at baseball a little bit
really I was okay did you get beaned a
lot because you're so tall well I leaned
into the pitches
did you ever charge the plate the mound
yeah
for the mound no I wasn't a fighting kid
oh I charged the flight people
then everybody dragged me off of him
with the bat yeah
you're supposed to
well he hit me on purpose and I chased
after him and then the refs and my dad
and other parents grabbed me so it was
like at the end of Casino for you
beating the crap out of a guy yeah he
was fat and I kept calling him pie that
was his nickname well that was his
nickname to me so when I got up to bed
he hit me with a ball that's awesome oh
it was fun I don't think Little League
pictures of that kind of control they
don't no this was probably when we were
like 14. poor velocities yeah they'd
probably do that yeah yeah it was
intentional yeah it would have hit him
harder if they hadn't gotten my gotten
my shoulder
anyway
so he should let's talk about this
though do you guys wear Balenciaga no no
I'd never heard of it until this story
I'm not gonna well what's amazing is the
there's a outfit that I don't know what
you call it I'm trying uh an outfit that
Kim Kardashian's wearing when she's
wearing all black with a face mask and
all that that's what Kanye's wearing on
the Alex Jones interview yeah so it's
the Valencia of uh Kim Kim Kardashian
yes one of those degenerates wearing uh
the the thing yeah and then there's so
many in the family it's hard to
distinguish yes between Gerald's playing
dumb he knows all the cartoon yeah
oh he loves them all he knows the half
Kardashians too yep there are half
Kardashians oh so that's what Kanye was
wearing yes yeah basically that huh
that's stylish
if you wanna I don't know dude
cut someone's ankles off while they do a
chair there you go yeah there are pure
Kardashians and then those are half
Caitlyn Jenner those are yeah those are
those are full they're sharp gals yeah
this is a great thing I'm a part of
who wore it better guys
[Laughter]
ah none of this world makes sense they
came it's Connie you can't borrow your
face mask thing yeah come on where'd you
get it Balenciaga
so uh Demi uh
he's the he's the uh Balenciaga creative
designer uh who came up with the kids
bondage bear campaign I don't know if
you guys remember that he apologized for
it by saying it was inappropriate to
have kids promote objects that had
nothing to do with them wait wait wait
wait wait hold on hold on
that's his that's his bar yeah so it was
two things one it was inappropriate it
inappropriate is not the right word it
was absolutely evil demonic and
abhorrent of me to allow a child to be
in an ad and let me just read the last
part instead of objects that had nothing
to do with them with
bears in leather whatever stuff that
it's a it's just bondage Bears really
like you're gonna have bondage bears and
children this is not objects that had
nothing to do with them this is not like
a Pepsi bottle sitting over on the side
nightstand and it was like oh that
doesn't really have anything to do that
it was bondage bears in their hands but
just say that you've never gone to build
a bear and added nipple clamps
I didn't realize that was an option
these Bears came with a shiny red ball
yes they did they they were like Teddy
Ruxpin except there was a gag the
reindeer knows that's not what it was
that was a gag it was a gag yes gotcha
so instead of it saying I love you it
was that Safety Orders banana so it goes
by the way Kim Kardashian does a lot of
uh black mask face here's another one
wow that's crazy is that her yeah
stupid
who's the one who's the Manish one the
little the younger one I don't know
maybe that's rude
um well in today's time I mean it could
be descriptive who knows well there's K
I don't care we're not gonna get into
don't get into Kardashians some of them
are cute
they're crazy yeah it's a woman
I'm jokingly I meant more I I love the
women all right I'm not I'm not here to
tell you I think you're equal
um
nothing all right we're gonna leave you
on that Branch by yourself boy I really
appreciate that guys nobody jumping in
just twisting that win did you ever buy
anything from Balenciaga no I wouldn't
know where to find this purse or
bondage bear [ __ ] the kids shoes all
right so but it turns out the CEO of
balenciaga's parent company Francois
Henry Pena Pino yo I'm sorry do you
wanna because you're a wine homo do you
want to go ahead and read that
yeah
please Gerald go ahead no no no no no no
please he owns a company that sells
child get this I thought this was fake
child sex mannequins with
penises on their face
look at that man what that really puts
the pedo in Geppetto guys I've been in
locker rooms that would make guys blush
with that kind of stuff this is this is
normal I can't believe you would sell
that well putting it on an adult would
be dumb and stupid and all of the other
words that you can think that mean the
same thing it would be bad enough but
you put it on a child yeah like why in
the world does anybody think that this
is a reasonable thing to do you're just
like lie to me
lie to me but no kissing thing
that I mean the story is so much
different now that's all it is though
it's Pinocchio but they made it a penis
yeah which is I'm sure the fantasy of a
lot of people
have a penis for a nose no to have a kid
that they made with one that's they
wanted to be a real boy
don't you mad at me all you want
the parody of yeah exactly I'm not
saying that I think the guy should be
murdered who invented it but I mean not
murdered I shouldn't say that uh
career-wise show really career-wise you
should be murdered and then later
it murdered
um no die suddenly yes I think you
should accidentally die
all right
but this Francois guy is not the one who
invented it and we don't wish death on
him no no I mean unless we have to Dave
no I think he's swelled shut up no sorry
this company sells kids with peace it's
not that I just why do I have to pretend
I like them you don't there should be
very very very very very harsh penalties
for things like this in our society you
know this elf on a shelf yeah he's
listening to me and I'm gonna get more
presents by the way I I just did really
quickly my wife and I went to a mall and
she saw like the Balenciaga she's like
how is that still up if somebody should
paint that was anybody in it no I mean
it was it was Neiman Marcus oh okay
Neiman Marcus had a bunch of the like
brand logos on the outside of the
building that they're advertising and we
just couldn't believe it it made my
wife's first thought was criminal action
yeah that's completely out of character
for my wife but criminal thoughts
entered her mind yeah that's the
response everybody should have to this
well yeah because you wanted to Splash
paint on it like you would someone like
that yeah we hate that stuff right we
hate when people do that but it's just
like our first reaction was how is that
even allowed to be here anymore right
don't say no it's Christmas time this
place is filled with families don't they
know that this is going on well but look
at these photos it's all just Snake Eyes
from GI Joe like there's not any efforts
going into it that's fair
look at that
ah it's uh
that's a good way to trick a guy to not
knowing you have anyway which brings us
to what uh this brings us to the seven
plus one rejected
Balenciaga products
[Music]
who is One in the Chamber every time
have you noticed that I did number seven
don't talk boy
oh my gosh
Gerald hey
number six the tickle me Haley Joel
Osmond
uh number five crawdaddy oh
Fister Potato Head
oh no
I'll take credit
number four uh this one was actually a
pretty hot seller she ma'am
it's a blur yes
number three Gerald a Easy Bake coffin
you gotta get rid of the evidence
yep oh never too
I just knew you were coming my way the
worst ones
Cube
uh number one
the Epstein bears
oh man
foreign
the last book you'll ever read
and number one
our number plus one yeah POG Patrol
oh yeah and this has been seven plus one
[Music]
button if you think uh Hitler's bad all
right still bad right still bad still
bad I'm still voting still not a fan
still not at all a fan not a big fan of
Hitler uh Nazis neither never gotta say
not a lot of good qualities nope
Western media reported fake news of uh
for authoritarian regime yesterday the
New York Times reported that I wait
wasn't do we Iran that's the country we
we bombed right you know what Dave Iran
what's Iran yeah Iran why don't you let
me take this one I'm gonna let you have
it baby yeah okay
guys I'm gay
you're real coward with that you know
you muted my mic and I can't even
respond that's right I see how it is all
right so look at the mic you just said
it what no that was not me that was me
but okay fine you just said it yesterday
the New York Times reported that Iran
will be abolishing its so-called
morality police comment if you've seen
this out there right now all of the news
organizations have been covering this
and we feel like they have been covering
this incorrectly for whatever reason uh
we'll get to that in just a second the
times actually had a headline that
initially read Iran abolishes morality
police after months of protest now yes
there have been months of protest and
yes it is because of what the morality
police did but writers at the Times Drew
this conclusion from a speech that was
given from Iran's attorney general
that's funny they have an attorney
general that's cute
it just I didn't know that you needed an
attorney general to kill your citizens
and kind of you know basically oppress
them in several different ways well it's
nice to have titles
that's true yeah right his name is the
Quran his name right no his well his
name starts with a familiar name uh
Muhammad
Montessori right where he said the
morality police was abolished by the
same authorities who installed it so
that's what they took and ran with and
basically thought okay well Iran is
taking some positive steps here and
they're going to abolish the morality
police the only problem is it's not true
right here's the actual full quote from
the Iranian attorney general the
morality police has nothing to do with
the Judiciary System the same source
that created it in the past from the
same place it has shut down of course
the Judiciary System will continue its
surveillance of social behaviors across
Society
down but they're going to continue to
monitor your behavior across Society
well what do you think that means the
morality police were basically going out
and making sure for instance that will
you is that what that means well maybe
women were wearing the hijab right yes
um we we covered something and I don't
know that we have it in here but maybe
if if you know control room if you guys
can find something on this do you
remember when the rock climber we
climber not rock climber she was in a
competition yeah and she was competing
for a you know Iran she had to climb on
short notice like they said hey you're
up now she didn't have the hijab on
because she was in the back right she
had to come out and climb without it
well I believe that her house has been
burned to the ground now
but I need to confirm that because I saw
some reports of that there was some
footage that was out there about that so
yeah they're real tolerant when women
don't have head coverings I get it
cultures are different I'm just saying
maybe don't burn down people's houses
for it that's what a lot of people are
asking for isn't it hard to climb a
mountain with a face not on her she
wasn't on a mountain no it's hard with a
full burger
no it's swimming with a full burka
that's that's difficult as well
it's called the beach burka yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah exactly so on our Twitter
journalist uh nahayat tizush and these
are really difficult names by the way
yeah now who's stupid yeah she outlined
the issues with the New York Times
reporting Montessori is not in charge of
the regime's morality police
um said mortality please what's the
difference
Montessori doesn't specify who allegedly
shut down the morality police and when
and how and Montessori promises to
continue enforcement of countries
Islamic Sharia laws which we saw right
so these are all kind of on the ground
reporters journalists these are sources
by the way that CNN the New York Times
Washington Post all these different
organizations that are you know the
trusted names and news democracy dies in
darkness and trust us above all else
they could have easily gone out and done
some research on this to find out so
Iranian journalist Sana ibrahimi
described this as a propaganda effort by
the regime here
the morality police has not been
abolished death temporarily stopped
working which is a suspension but we
know for a fact it's not abolished they
are not going to change anything and
even if they do that that's not what
people are demanding for people are
asking for freedom and their dignity and
they're not going to rest until then
that's only achievable by overthrowing
the regime they want nothing but
abolishing the regime itself so this is
just the regime propaganda that is has
been spreaded by
um regime's Lobby and its arms in in the
west ah okay so at the very best this
looks like a bit of propaganda at the
very worst she has a treasure trailer
she had some adorable dimples though if
you show those dimples though should we
airlift manscaped to Iran as well oh
yeah we should just drop it you know
like humanitarian Aid kind of thing
where normally it's food but this is
just manscape for sure yeah I think it's
something
[Laughter]
trust me you'll thank us they all just
break so it's just an insult oh well I
think if you drop anything out of a
plane I'm not speaking of the durability
I mean come on we have advancements
that's true I do I do have tiny manscape
parachutes I've made that's right it's
your little army soldier parachutes I've
made it out of what I shave ah okay this
is the Dave collection
they may need to be recharged a little
more frequently yes they do my mine went
dull very quick well you have to you're
the guy at the end of the line testing
the product every time yes shaving to
see if it works yeah Dave's got quite a
forest tropical rain farts coming out of
it like Dumb and Dumber yeah
the grinder texture of a Brillo pad so
look there is speculation that the
regime might want to distract from an
upcoming planned three-day strike like
these these protests are are not going
away the Iranian national soccer team
obviously we talked about them in the
World Cup and the protest that they had
so this stuff is not going away this is
a big thorn in the side of the regime
but it's unclear
um if if that was necessarily A factor
that was involved in this but it's it's
the timing is kind of coincidental
um so again the major Lobby group in the
US called the national Iranian Council
it's been characterized by protesters as
an arm of the regime these guys may have
been involved is what I was saying there
but it's unclear they were instrumental
in getting the Iranian nuclear deal
passed if you guys remember that it was
basically pallets of cash I believe
which is not not the best thing to do is
just to buy people off and let them
continue doing what they're doing um
unabated and the New York Times to their
credit did eventually change its
headline to include the words official
says this right so that's not uh that's
that's they they still didn't read the
rest of the quote so it's so by the way
can you pull that back up pull the Yeah
Yeah Dave would miss that says oh skate
right over that this is the Brilliance
right this is the Brilliance Iran
abolishes morality police after months
of protests how do you know that
go into it in the article that somebody
would say that is it is it normal for
someone to say something that is about
to happen yes otherwise how do you know
it either it's a press release or
somebody says it so they put in there an
official says it's like yes but I
already assumed that I already assumed
somebody said that that's why you guys
found out you'd correct the story and
basically say he also said we're going
to continue policing our citizens so
it's basically the same thing right so
and this look we support a lot of awful
people we do we have a lot of regimes
that we are in bed with or at least our
media Outlets don't push on quite as
hard as they should absolutely unless
Saudi Arabia Saudi Arabia yeah exactly
Saudi Arabia they would absolutely go
after but Iran for some reason that
seems to be a bit of a bridge too far
hit the like button by the way if you
like us and do not like so we've already
covered hit learn the Nazis but hit the
like button if you don't like
Iranian oppression of their citizens
maybe in killing people for not wearing
a hijab yeah go ahead hit the like
button you don't like don't like that
Iranian citizens being murdered yeah I
don't that's kind of like kind of like
the Arab Spring you know did that affect
a lot of change lasting change I don't
know
yeah I mean I don't know if they can be
fixed maybe but if we get enough likes
it'll fix nothing
well look don't forget shows we care
this is sure this this is not I don't
think this is a coincidence New York
Times has carried water before look at
that mustache I'm sorry that was
completely out of line how dare you I
could have kept that to myself but she's
interviewing a walrus
let's just see we'd rather use use a
flashlight or things like that oh that's
good yeah great information if there's a
power outage yeah during the winter yes
flashlight will certainly keep me warm
yeah that'll be good here so you'll be
frozen solid where with a flashlight
we'll know how to find you we'll see the
flashlight just in One Direction that's
good it's gonna have to wait till spring
to bury you do us a favor point it up at
your face and wedge it into the snow so
it's like a scary flashlight Lantern guy
you know it'd be fantastic just you dead
Frozen oh that's probably what Wilfred
Brimley would look like had he not
gotten all the Beaters
[Laughter]
just a healthy old Foo man chewed fella
anyway sorry I did not interrupt you go
ahead but that would I just like a good
Fu Man true so do you remember the New
York Times after we killed uh kasim
solomani yes when uh when Donald Trump
is that L bag Daddy no different guy
okay same different guy the New York
Times I bet they smelled alike or sorry
they tweeted this obit with this caption
kasim solomani master of Iran's Intrigue
and force
ties at 62. you missed a few things
there right master of Iran's Intrigue
and force I don't know what that means
and I don't think anybody else knows
what that means other than he was their
Chief torturer by the way that probably
would have been a better catchphrase and
diet 62 kind of you know he didn't just
you know fall over and choke on a
hamster fired it wasn't peacefully yeah
he did not die peacefully no no no it's
one of those you know surgical strikes
where we saw his car and then his car
was no more and there was fire on the
screen so that's that's how he died was
he driving a gremlin
uh no Chevy Nova yes
it really depends on the automobiles it
was the pinto guys yeah yeah oh it's too
bad he didn't have the Cadillac where
they have the metal plate built into the
car you know it was the new hydrogen to
keep you from the Flames yes yeah the
firewall yeah there was one that's how
uh Detroit yeah that's how Ace Rothstein
lived in casinos because they had the
metal plate yeah he was still burnt they
don't blow you up plates just in case
people want to blow you up I guarantee
that was somebody in Detroit who was
like there's got to be a way to stop
these things from completely exploding
yeah well so they also the New York
Times They also ran a puff piece on him
that same week and just just so you know
solomani was a puff piece on a torturer
uh torture yeah well and he was also
directly responsible for the deaths of
Americans in Iraq right it was also
known information at the time so it's
not like we just Unearthed this oh no
right so how did you how did they fluff
it up for us to make it palatable they
basically do it by Omission they don't
tell you everything about this guy they
say he died at 62. they say he was a
minister of whatever in Iran's regime
master and Intrigue which is a weird
name
Dungeons and Dragons kind of group name
that you'd come up with I'm not sure but
look it's not just the New York New York
Times that reported the story wrong so
did Face the Nation watch I want to
start with some breaking news overnight
out of Iran they have abolished the
morality police this is after Monster
protests following the death of Masa
amini who died this was yesterday she
was taken to custody since her head
wasn't adequately covered does this
stops that have been raging that's up to
the Iranian people this is about them uh
it's not about us and what we've seen I
don't have a spot killing of masamini
that guy's in Iraq in the extraordinary
courage of Iranian young people
especially women who've been leading
these protests do you stand with them
for the right to be able to say what
they want to say where what they want to
wear and so if the regime has now
responded in some fashion to those
protests that could be a positive thing
but we have to see how it actually plays
out in practice and what the Iranian
people think this is about them and it's
up to them throw some balls I know right
that was the Secretary of State Anthony
blinken by the way so you think these
people out like Anthony blumpkin well
he could have said this so easily
and we stand with them yeah we stand
with her
who was killed for doing what she was
asked to do arrested and beaten by the
police until she died from it yeah
that's pretty clear she didn't cover her
head so they removed it yes right yeah
so that seems fair yeah there's no
there's no objective right or wrong with
these people they can't oh that's it's
up to them whatever whatever they feel
is right and it's so wrong that's what's
amazing is anything that they even
consider objectively right like this is
wrong it's completely wrong and why I
hate the fact that you get even pundits
like that though who are like well you
know I don't wanna I don't wanna I don't
wanna crap on their culture of you know
murdering a woman who won't wear a silly
hat yes no and look I get it like when
you're talking about
um you know foreign policy I understand
that there is a bit of a game that you
have to play to try to affect change
yeah regimes into Corners sometimes and
they can become more violent especially
against their own citizens but I don't
hold out any hope that that's actually
what's going on with this administration
because Biden and Obama were the people
who did the deal with Iran in the first
place to give them cash all over the
place I don't think that they are
actually going to push back and they're
saying well we're just playing the long
game Joe you've been in office for about
50-ish years now right you took a little
bit of a break because you guys couldn't
win and you had every opportunity as
Vice President of the United States to
affect change in Iran and support the
Iranian people they've been protesting
for a very long time in Iran at
different points and the United States
hasn't stood up and said you know what
we backed the people of Iran nearly
enough I guarantee you right now if
president Trump was in office and this
was going on it wouldn't be that kind of
statement that we would be getting no we
would be getting a well and maybe it
would get us in a lot of trouble because
he would tweet it out with a Diet Coke
can in his one hand yeah and I'm sure
they'd yeah they maybe cut out the parts
they needed to make it look better but
look other outlets are also not
reporting on this accurately as well so
we have the AFP we have uh daily wire I
think is one of these Outlets that we
had up there as well the BBC Bloomberg a
lot of conservative Outlets even ran
with his story not picking on anybody in
particular but that was one of the ones
that we saw and it's okay to say hey
sometimes people drop the ball so this
is a great opportunity to come back and
correct the record on this right so make
sure that we get it right this is what's
going on in Iran and it's not that
they're abolishing the morality police
and all of a sudden changing trust me
Ayatollah command is not going to allow
that to happen well it's a great
opportunity to talk about what is Sharia
law based on based on the Quran what's
the constitution based on based on
judeo-christian principles why is one
exceptional and one will never advance
and it's just you know use these
opportunities to to show the difference
the huge difference between what this
American experiment is and these people
that are living in the 7th Century well
and it's so easy to almost talk about
now because everything is so I don't
know it's so watered down you're so used
to hearing such painful things but like
this is a human being this is a woman
who did absolutely nothing wrong
murdered right her life was taken away
and this is fine with an entire culture
why do we want to keep pretending that's
okay it's it's disgusting and
unacceptable why is Sharia why is this
okay the Quran oh don't say that why of
course come on let's you know the you
can crap on every other religion the
sunlight is what you've got to expose
this stuff that's what free speech is
about when else you have Kanye saying
whatever you want you're not going to
have yeah that's true but you don't have
you know going at people who that that
their religion doesn't react like that
it's a serious problem you're murdering
people and like this is a uh I just hate
it I find it so disgusting that you
would kill a human being over face wear
and we're still living in a time where
like we're talking to you on the
internet right now surrounded by you
know microphones and there's guys
building electric cars and this culture
is still like oh she's not wearing a
face mask even though she did what we
asked her to do let's murder her
property I get that I know they want to
be modest and and you know they see our
culture and what that goes with freedom
I get it yep we have Megan the stallion
my bad you know we understand we've got
your cardi B's yeah I'd rather have
Megan the stallion who's allowed to show
her body than somebody who's murdered
because they didn't no I agree I mean
sure no that's what you know Freedom
that's the thing about America is like
people don't realize how lucky we are to
have this yeah well look and cultures go
through their kind of Evolutions right
and we understand that they're going to
be protests along the way there's going
to be a lot of stuff that happens the
regime is not going to want to lose
control or lose power all we're saying
is look I get that we can't go and just
replicate American exactly absolutely
but when these cultures start to stand
up like in China like in Iran we need to
be there to support them we need to be
there to say yes that's a good thing now
you're like well it could destabilize
yeah because the Middle East has been a
stable place for the last 50 years you
guys plan has worked so swimmingly well
that neria war has been fought over
there right so screw it I'm done I'm
done trying to appease regimes that we
hate and this includes Saudi Arabia by
the way this includes Qatar and places
like that I'm not a big fan of throwing
gay people off of buildings and seeing
if they can fly for the thousandth time
just to see if you can prove the point
okay I'm also not a fan of throwing
death and human suffering at
constructing stadiums so that you can
host a World Cup not my thing 6 000 plus
people I think have died during the
construction of those stadiums I'm just
saying let's stop playing like we like
these cultures let's just call them out
when they need to be called out and
let's just support their citizens when
they yearn for freedom and if you think
you're liberal or have any idea of what
that actually meant at one time you
certainly don't support the murder of
somebody underneath under these
ridiculous dictatorships no absolutely
and the people are great like I I
they're oh I'm not knocking the people
I'm trying to help them that's what I
said no it's not it's the cultures it's
not just that it's the cultures that are
imposed on them right of course
leadership that's right that's what I'm
referring to Gerald I love that you
didn't you didn't say cutter cutter
where'd that come from I don't know I'm
not sure which one's correct but I
always said guitar it's guitar right
there was a movie called Qatar now they
call it cutter there's also acoustic
guitar oh geez electric guitar oh lord
well
I'm glad you let me take and run with
that one well you know what Gerald's
this is when Gerald knows stuff
[Music]
Echo he got an Echo come on yeah well I
don't know how he did it when he had
effects on that he's working over the
weekend just to screw with me yeah he
don't like you nope
nope never piss off the soundboard guy
no I don't know what you did to him I
don't either um she's giving him that
back rub support him with my brother
yeah you filthy animal uh one thing
really fast lane uh guitar says 400 to
500 migrant workers died due to the
World Cup but it's actually unrevealed 6
500 magnum workers have died six
thousand whoa even the Egyptians the
Egyptians are blushing and like guys
that's a little much I'm no math
mammarian but I'd say that's a thousand
times more yeah
Chinese are like well that's about what
it takes to build a good wall yeah no it
seems right you know except theirs took
forever and that one day just died in a
week and a half yeah exactly well it's
174 000 degrees there so that's I pretty
I know a lot of people that have been
stationed in the Middle East
and several people have said God doesn't
want you to live there
there's nothing it's insanely hot no it
no nothing should be alive you have
cobras that come inside to stay cool
is it cool if we come in here it's kind
of hot out there yeah I've heard yeah
nobody is like oh I love the weather
it's great it's just it's a step right
before hell
and spiders follow you
to rest in your Shadow yeah
well they're not even with they're going
to attack you they're just like look man
I'm not gonna just need to cool down yes
and shade my way come on they've got
like a little white flag just yeah look
I I know I'm hard to look at but I'm
just I just need some cool it's been a
rough life
I'll make you a nice web you like webs
no oh okay that's all I got all I got
man I got a house in my ass now I'm
gonna bite you gonna bite you if you
move yeah stay put down the size of a
dinner plate
people are gonna Google it and find out
it's true oh yeah it's like a crab
that's following you well that's why
like every animal there is designed to
murder you eight seconds after it bites
you like oh you carry water in your okay
fantastic all drinks moisture in yeah
yeah this is perfect yeah there's
something with your eyes there's no
reason to be there
you're at about a hijab you know how
many spiders was probably up on that
mountain
by a lot breach amen I don't like
spiders at all no I'll say it you know
what spiders I don't even want you to
watch this show they don't they're not
hate eyes I I don't like that either I
don't think why can't you have two like
your cartoons can I don't have any of
that
why why the spider
people say if you could ask God one
question I'm not asking about the spider
the spider does I'm gonna ask him a
question I'm gonna go couldn't you make
it like cool
like if a spider looked like a hamster
you'd be like yeah I got some spiders in
my house they ate bugs
[Laughter]
I like it that they eat mosquitoes
mosquitoes is the question I'm not
saying they shouldn't eat mosquitoes
you're getting me all wrong I'm saying
make them cute yeah uh you want it to be
like a Charlotte's Web kind of spider
yes oh got it which is still kind of
gross
but less gross less gross all right
because it talked and was like oh hello
Charlotte Pig we're like wow you can
spell yeah I've made a way of being not
me
I think you're so good spiders good
anyway I hate you a Canadian woman who
was also a veteran called in for support
for her chair lift oh you heard about
this yes and was told that we cannot
help you but they instead offered
assistant suicide
that's right he needed a chair lift to
go up the stairs ah and instead Fresh
Out literally look we can't really get
your chair right now we can murder you
for Christine goetzier the fight to get
a wheelchair lift in her home has been
an uphill battle I have to crawl down
the stairs on my on my butt with the
wheelchair in front of me
to be able to access my my house while
pleading her case to a Veterans Affairs
case manager over the phone in 2019 she
was told something that would leave her
feeling shocked if things are so hard at
this point and uh you just can't keep
going on and you know we can assist you
with the egg to die and she's not the
only one
so so let's say you support assistant
suicide you've learned extreme amounts
of pain that should be up to the person
not really the doctor going hey want me
to kill you yeah well basically I was
looking for maybe delivery in the next
six to eight weeks you're saying it's
going to be longer and that I should
accept death and yeah here you got a
couple options we can get you one by
July or we can come by and I don't know
snuff you out what one do you prefer is
there maybe a middle ground hey sounds
like you want to meet God can I pay for
expedited shipping perhaps yes I'll pay
the fee you can't get up the stairs then
kill yourself maybe move into a a single
story residence something we can work
something out yeah there's no middle
ground it's just like yeah I can't get
you a chair lift but I can have a group
of people and your life yes we'll help
you with the dying Veterans Affairs I I
don't really care about if you have to
crawl up your stairs I don't care well
you're a veteran ah thank you for your
service mounties we do appreciate that
by the way we will serve you and kill
you yeah speak in a service do you have
a firearm yeah hello yeah just point
that at yourself that's illegal though
but we're gonna let this one slide
because it helps us with the paperwork
we're just gonna swing some somebody by
to cut your gas lines and we'll have you
all set within the next couple days you
know that bucket maple syrup we all love
it just put your head directly in the
bucket so you're Frozen to the carpet
yeah heal you off like velcro
all you away
oh it sounds like a Make-a-Wish and your
wish is death have you ever gone ice
fishing in July yeah give it a try yeah
it's good what we're gonna do is wait
for it to thaw out and then just shove
you out there how does that work
no I just want to walk I just trying to
get up the stairs yeah you're stupid
we heard you the first time really we're
gonna say we're gonna send you to hell I
uh
so in fact uh this is actually even a
bigger story Canadian authorities are
reportedly not only offering that but
now they're demanding use of their new
chairlift service
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
works well that way they could only
install it once and they can just
recycle it to every Veteran's house
[Laughter]
on our way up the stairs she knocks the
portrait of skew just a bit and it
freezes on that like that's the travesty
of what's Happening yeah
yeah there's a picture out of alignment
oh oh my God boy Canada you guys are
something that's uh but here's the gal
that you know served her country yes
needs some help as opposed to the people
at Walmart that use the electric chairs
because they're lazy oh yeah and I I
feel that if uh if you are that big
you should just run in front of that
person and take the cart have you ever
done that it's really funny because
there's no law that says you can't use
it that's right it's just a rule that
we've all decided to abide by of not
being a jerk but it's not a law what are
they gonna catch you yeah exactly if
you're like sorry suggestions like
somebody's like you know those things
aren't that fast no but they're like six
you're gonna catch it yeah it's still
not gonna catch you yeah if you ever
have you ever tipped anybody on it
oh yeah you just get like four guys and
tip a Walmart Scooter
if you jump on him like Super Mario
Brothers bunch of chocolate coins come
out
like if you're going around Walmart
because you're morbidly OB no offense I
like them curvy too but if you're going
around to Walmart in one of those using
a reaching stick to get your groceries
yeah maybe maybe you need a call from
the Canadian government
[Laughter]
government I'm here to help well she was
French Canadian so she's going to have a
tough time with Ottawa what's amazing
though is she's completely of sound mind
yeah like there's no reason for her to
have to die because she would like to
get up the stairs easier she was a
little impatient and waiting for her
chair lifts right yeah you know which
one tends to get when months go by and
you can't get upstairs to use the
bathroom that's upstairs well that was
poor planning yeah yeah well we'll just
put you down for one death sentence no
chair no no shut up no I can't hear you
once we gain the selection it cannot be
unselected I'm sorry oh I thought you
said grenade ah so yeah
yeah look I personally am one of the few
people and I'm sure a lot of people will
be mad but I'm fine if you are in
massive amounts of pain and that is your
choice
I have some assistance suicide
look I'm just saying that's your choice
that's an interesting question it is an
interesting question we could and it's
just my opinion I'd never thought
Kevorkian was a bad guy yeah I
personally didn't um well I mean when he
started doing it for fun it was weird
but in the beginning it made sense we
made you sign over your will and
everything that's that was the parts
that were bad but there's more
professional looking van he had yeah
yeah did you ever see the suicide
machine it looks like he made it with
like a bike pump and some bleach oh geez
it's only hurt for about six or seven
hours yeah don't worry it's it's it's
kind of like uh yeah it's kind of like
the what do they call when they put you
on death row and they shoot you with the
lethal injection yeah it looks like that
except it took way longer you gotta
pedal it yourself yeah it's a Peloton
until you get pass out
oh well good luck Canada
and uh that's it I think for today's
show yeah again check me out this
weekend I'll be at the comedy castle
that's in Detroit Royal Oak Detroit
going back to your roots yeah I'm going
back to the the club I started in nice
nice I made the mistake of sitting front
row with um the Pitbull of Comedy what
was his name again that was uh yes
Gallagher no no it was uh and I can't
believe I'm blanking on his name I can
see him he has gray hair uh very very
vile yeah it talks like that every joke
is extremely offensive yeah the whole
night long my wife and I were Joni and
Chachi and he would call back to us oh
I'm so mad I can't think of his name
right now and I know it too the ah look
how Pitbull a comedy I'm not leaving
till we get it oh no no people pay for a
show they can listen to us like look at
this stuff Bobby's sleeping thank you
Bobby Slayton yes Google him it's fun
for the whole family sit around during
the holidays to listen to for Christmas
yeah throw it on them Christmas morning
so never tip the maitre Dita Comedy Club
to get you good seats don't do it no no
no it's best to not be in the very front
row I've always said that and I'm a
comic yeah I don't mean I don't really
go with people though but sometimes
well I put a clip up on my uh I hate to
say a tick tock but I got one a couple
weeks ago where I was like hey what what
are those uh the guy's crutches and I
didn't know they were and I go oh did
you break something you go snow I have
MS and I was like oh
and then I was like well I mean at least
they look cool and he goes I I guess and
I go okay so I guess you're compliment
taking skills are handicapped as well
oh
and fortunately he was a fan of the show
so it was fun but I'm like I'm gonna
just go ahead and walk my way out of
this you know because I can walk and uh
and it's so fun because like Crowder
fans get it you know they laugh and he's
enjoying it and loving it and stuff so
it was fun to play with but I honestly
didn't know what what it was and it is
of a Heckler who was a burn victim yes
to me yeah yeah the voice
and he's just terrified on stage yeah
[Music]
it burns it burns that was such a
brilliant because he started crying
right yeah he did yeah the tears they
burn
well thank you guys very much for tuning
in we're going to be back tomorrow uh
Stephen will be back in the big chair
and we will have on of course Mr Alex
Jones yeah I want to thank fraud Daddy
thank you Dave for coming I want to
thank all these guys for the hard work
you do Ahoy Gerald a yeah of course
he'll be back and no thank no thank you
Hugh thank you Dave thank you
and uh until tomorrow piss off YouTube
[Music]